[Music]
if if the idea of a multiverse is real
that is if our universe is not all there
is but there are other realms that are
rightly called universes of their own
and that's what question is can we go
there can we visit those other universes
and the short answer is no but the
longer answer is it really does depend
on the flavor of multiverse that you
have in mind
the most prominent two examples are that
maybe there are multiple Big Bang's
therefore multiple universes created
from those big bangs and to travel from
one universe to another would be
impossible because we can't leave our
universe it turns out leaving our
universe to go to another would be
basically the same thing as trying to go
back in time before the Big Bang that
created our universe even happened and
that's something which I don't think we
can do the other prominent example comes
from quantum physics quantum physics
says that the math of a theory only can
predict a probability of one outcome or
another electron 50% chance here a 50%
chance there the question is when you
measure the electron and find it here
what happened to the other possibility
well one proposal is it actually takes
place but in another universe all of the
possible outcomes described by the math
of quantum physics might actually happen
they just all happen to happen in
different universes now again the
question is can you travel from one
universe to another well the interesting
thing is you already have if these ideas
are correct because the possibility of
you going left or you going right are
you saying yes are you saying no these
are again possible quantum outcomes of
physical processes so if everything
happens then each of those happened as
well so this morning when you're
deciding between having pancakes or eggs
yeah you had both pancakes in one
universe and eggs in another so in that
sense you're constantly traveling
between these different universes
because every possible outcome is being
realized by you in all these different
realms